this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it is the ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about just about everything your life
your money your relationships
i'm john doloni joined here by my good
friend george campbell and we are taking
your calls on everything so give us a
shout triple-a 825-5225
if you are like millions and millions of
americans who are just struggling
money's hard right now it's a mess and
it's scary and it's
just it's a mess man i just drove by the
gas station i gotta go fill my car up
right after i get off and like it's
tough man
and if you're scared about that if your
relationships are a mess you're heading
into the summer um give us a call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
let's go out to luke in denver colorado
what's up luke
hey how are you doing we're good man how
are
you good so um my question is um i have
a question um basically trying to make
my parents understand
um a financial question so they know
your baby steps but um we they have come
into an inheritance and i'm trying to
help them understand um that it's better
to pay off their house rather than
leaving all the money and you know on
the stock and 401k so that's kind of my
question today
awesome so the great will smith once
said
to take it from him parents just don't
understand and it's gonna be hard for
you to do this man uh
george can walk you through the math
part um
tell me they understand the baby steps
or let me just back out you're not gonna
help your parents understand this unless
they ask for that sort of wisdom from
you
um have you sat down and said hey i
think this would be the wisest thing or
hey y'all know the baby steps have
worked for y'all here's what dave and
his team say about what's what comes
next have you had that conversation
yeah i've had a small conversation with
him mainly just my dad thinks that he
can make more money in the stock market
i just think that he's he's in sales and
so he gets really stressed out and i
think it's more of an emotional thing
and for him to be you know for him to
finally pay it off i'm trying i'm just
worried about him you know dude he's
lucky to have you he's lucky to have you
um george what do you think man well i
just i go back to pbs powdered butt
syndrome parents don't want to hear it
from the kid who you know they changed
your diaper man and so they're going
this kid's going to give me financial
advice i don't think so so i love the
heart behind it and yes you can show
them math all day long and truthfully
your dad's doing the math on paper he's
a sharp guy he's going i can make way
more on my investments but you just told
me he's stressed out what's he stressed
about
well it's just you know he's in sales
and so i think anyone knows how that
goes it's just very stressful sometimes
and i think that paying off this house
would alleviate some of the stress
because i can see it sometimes how old
are you luke
20. 20.
okay so i i don't have any fancy
psychological studies or anything to
tell you i'm just gonna tell you what i
would do if i was you
i would take dad out for coffee or for a
donut or something and i'd say hey i'm
just gonna say this one time and then
we're gonna go back to everything's the
way it was and he'll look at you kind of
weird and
i would tell him hey
since i've known you you've worked
really really hard and you've been uh
you're a great salesman and that comes
with a lot of stress
and there's been seasons when you've
been really stressed and you have an
opportunity to take a huge chunk of that
stress off your plate forever by paying
your house off yeah and i know you can
go back you think you can go time the
market and make good money um and now
it's not stock markets on sale so we're
going to dump all this money in there i
get that
that you're gonna be able to breathe if
you pay your house off
that's why
millions of people do it they get out of
debt and then they go chase the market
down and try to make money in real
estate and investing
but i'd have that conversation and say
hey i'm 20. you literally have wiped my
butt dad and you don't want to hear it
from me i love that george pbs i'll have
to keep that in my back pocket and let
that be the end of it okay but here's
what we're doing we're not trying to
sell them on the math we're not trying
to sell them on because there's this
magic plan we're selling them on hey i
see you dad and i love you and you got a
shot to be less stressed for the rest of
your life and that's a totally different
approach you hear what i'm saying
yeah no it definitely makes sense that's
definitely good could he wipe out the
entire mortgage with this inheritance
and still have money left over
oh yeah i mean he
i mean i can give you the numbers if
you'd like sure i'm just curious
yeah yeah so my both his parents both
died in succession a month apart um but
uh they they uh
he's getting 1.6 million um from
everything wow and uh he's worth he has
about a million dollar house about a
million investments he did tell me that
so he's like i'm fine i can invest this
in the market and he only knows about
120 000. i just think he said that he
can just make like 30 or 40 grand more
on the if he has eight years left on his
mortgage gosh don't pay it off
this is such a small percentage of the
inheritance of everything it's a small
percentage of what you got left
he's gonna be fine
i mean he doesn't need the money for
retirement
yeah exactly i mean he's he's in good
shape i just don't understand he just
thinks he can make more money in the
stock market and how old is he right now
so he's 51 so he's got plenty of life
left plenty of working career left so
i'm just going how much life does he
want to live in between retirement where
he would have that mortgage payment
freed up to do who knows what to give
more to go on vacations to
you know to be a blessing to the family
and whoever in this community so i look
at it through that lens too but listen
i'm a ramsay guy i can't convince my own
parents to pay off their house
and so
now if they had 1.6 million dollars
sitting around it may be an easier
discussion but at the end of the day
he's gonna be okay whether or not he
pays off his house today or eight years
from now uh he's not broke and so that
was my question if this guy's broke it's
a different situation yeah all right
let's go to uh anthony in jacksonville
hey anthony what's up
hey hey thanks for having me on i just
had a few questions for some advice go
for it
okay so
uh i get out of the military in the next
few months
and
my wife and i we bought our house a few
years back for 150 000
and we plan on moving back to my home
state of mississippi
and so we're trying to determine if you
think it would be a good idea where we
have the opportunity to sell it right
now for 260 which would pay off all of
our debt and we could move in with her
mom for the my remainder that i have for
about five or six months where we
wouldn't put we wouldn't have to pay
any rent or anything
until we start looking for a new home in
mississippi where it's a lot cheaper
than here in jacksonville
my rule of thumb is generally if there's
a
period at the end of that sentence so
and what i mean by that is we're going
to sell our house we're going to cash
out right now because the market's still
bonkers and then we're just going to
move in with my parents so we're going
to figure out what comes next that's
when relationships get melted down
because it that one month was gonna be
here for a couple of months turns into
two years turns into are you leaving
it's a mess
you saying hey we're gonna cash out yeah
we're gonna get completely debt free
we're gonna do this for five months and
then we're heading back to another part
of the country where we wanna make our
um our home outside of the military dude
i don't i think that's great man what do
you think yeah i like this plan as long
as you said four or five months and then
you said you were gonna start looking so
i would start looking when you move in
and start to get a feel for do we have
enough money what kind of house what
area start making plans at that point so
it doesn't drag on and anthony uh we've
done this enough let me tell you what
would be a real gift to you your wife
and your mother-in-law
sit down take them to a nice dinner
and sit down and say okay let's come up
with all the rules
when do you want us
you know like and i'm being serious
about
how late or early do you want us um in
the house like is it make you
uncomfortable people are coming and
going after midnight um i'll make the
coffee i'll do to take care of the lawn
go ahead and set all that stuff up so
there's not any weird tension on day one
when you all move in and you are gonna
have to work my brother because your
work you're used to living with a bunch
of
knuckleheads and now you're moving in
with your mother-in-law so you're gonna
have to level away what you're gonna
have to shower every day probably all
right thank you so so much for your
service my brother congratulations on
being debt-free we'll be right back on
the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm john dolone
joined by my good friend george campbell
and we're taking your calls on money in
life it's triple eight eight two five
five two two five it's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's go to greg in
boise idaho most beautiful places in the
country what's up greg
ooh i agree with that 100
um so here's what i've got going on i'm
in baby steps four five and six
uh starting a new job in a week and the
new job has a quarterly
option to buy
into the company stock at a 10 discount
do you
take part of your 15 of your investment
portfolio and allocate it towards that
or if i want to take advantage of that
do i need to find
uh money in my budget to throw at that
that is not part of the investment
strategy of the 15 percent
great great question greg and that's
awesome that you're even thinking about
the stuff how old are you
34. okay
fantastic well if i'm in your shoes i'm
investing 15
into the 401k beyond that if you want to
play with some money with the employee
stock program i'm okay with that we're
not huge fans of it because essentially
you're investing into a single stock at
a slight discount
and so we don't know the future of this
company uh john's got a very personal
story about his mom my mom worked for
enron
and oh no yes and uh and
less because
we didn't have a lot of money growing up
but
it wasn't that she had a ton of money in
there but we did have a number of family
friends that were high up in that
company who went to bed
multi-millionaires and woke up literally
with nothing right and so i've got a
i've got a personal
uh
buy back stock plans or discounted stock
plans um on the backs of it's kind of i
feel like it's like me talking to my son
who's 12 and being like hey listen
um i'm gonna let you buy shares of your
own room what do you think about that
right and it just feels gross to me um
but that's not to say you can't make
some great money in the co i don't want
to say every company is in run because
they're most certainly are not so it may
work out great for you sure i just like
investing 15 into mutual funds in your
401k because it's so diversified way
less risk than a single stock of one
company so if you said hey should i go
put all my money just into tesla i would
say no so the same applies to your
company here now i understand they're at
a discount so if you're going to play
with this after the 15
i would sell them after you get them so
that you kind of cash out and then you
can invest that money and that way
you're going to be better off in the
long run so and i george that's that's a
great idea i hadn't thought about that
so if you
buy the stock with the 10 discount and
it i'm sure it's got some vesting period
and you then you go sell it you've
you've made 10 on that money every time
yeah and there may be some capital gains
taxes so make sure you look into the tax
implications of whatever you're selling
uh but i did this john when i first
worked at apple i was a young buck at 18
and they had a stock purchase program
which was awesome at the time because
this was you know 09 2010 iphone was hot
and so i ended up selling some stock to
get out of debt which was which i was
very pleased with uh but again there's
some risk there now apple's a very it's
an outlier company yeah yeah now i don't
know greg's company but i don't think
it's apple most and that's the hard part
is uh daniel kahneman wrote about this
so beautifully if you all haven't read
the book thinking fast thinking slow
it's one of the most important books
ever written but he talks about how it's
so tempting to look back and say if i
had just bought tesla
then i would be a gazillionaire and you
don't think about all of the battery
manufacturers or electric car companies
that gave it a shot and went and got got
funding and that we don't hear about
because they don't exist there's way
more of those than there is of course
absolutely apples right yeah and so
we're not a fan of single stocks because
of the volatility you're putting all
your eggs in that one basket so i like
you investing 15
into the retirement plan into something
boring like a 401k and if you got money
left over that beyond that you want to
play with it'd be something similar to
crypto or i'm like hey if you lose this
money i put it in and then forget that
you ever had it and if you make 10 minus
capital gains make the spread on that
man good for you good fantastic i like
that all right let's go to palin in
washington what is up palin
how's it going sir how are you doing
today dude we're doing fantastic and
yourself
awesome man awesome hey i just spread
the money total money makeover and i'm
fired up man
fantastic it'll do that to you awesome
so my question is we had some trips
planned before we decided we want to do
this
payoff debt and stuff like that now the
first trip is here in a couple months
here in july we're going to be going
camping
everything's paid for everything all the
money is set aside we're ready to go
now
i'm okay with canceling that trip just
my wife and my kids would be a little
bit of upset
um so i'm in and another thing we have
another trip planned in about 2025 we're
just gonna go to florida and see some
relatives
should i cancel these trips tell it
completely debt-free i'm guesstimating
i'll be debt-free in
i don't know two years i got about 50
grand in total debt
so what is your guys's advice did you
say you're going on this other trip in
2025
yeah we're kind of planning way ahead
right wow i don't know what's happening
next weekend this guy's next i literally
don't know what day it is right now man
i just got back in town palin i don't
know what day john plans on the world
ending before then so he's not planning
yeah there's no way
well to answer your question never know
anymore how much is this camping trip
total so uh total probably 1500 bucks
okay and then you have 50 grand in debt
uh
i'd go camping what do you think george
i mean here's the thing if if you can
make up the 1500 bucks with some side
hustles i'm i go okay
we'll let this one roll it's not gonna
set you back that much but if i'm in
your shoes i may go how do we make this
trip less expensive and still do
something fine
i'm wrong i was wrong because you've
gone camping right i mean i did it cheap
i leave in the morning we're going to go
camping and palin we're going to do a
koa
and which by the way are incredible
there you go for your free advertisement
but that place is my favorite place in
the world
i don't know how you're going to spend
1500 camping unless you're glamping the
point of camping was that it's cheap
that feels pretty pricey
yeah it's a boat in camping uh just cost
of fuel food tent camping is basically
what we're doing okay for about a week
yeah if you do drive a mile or two
that's going to cost you a good 1500
bucks in a week so that's probably true
um so palin here's the thing i i was
wrong um
i think
the example you will set for your family
the commitment and passion you will
communicate to your family about how
important it is to get out of debt
is more important than a 1500 vacation i
do agree with george
that does not mean that you don't do
something as a family i think you all
get a tent or you get a small cabin for
50 bucks and you all go do a weekend
thing together um y'all camp out in the
yard y'all go figure out some things
y'all can do locally but i think this is
one of those um stake in the ground
moments we're not going on vacation
family we're i dug this whole
us as a family we dug this hole and us
as a family are gonna work like um
maniacs to get out of this and here's
what you're gonna find real quick you're
free from that fifty thousand dollars
the side hustles and the energy you put
into this work is going to magnify into
a raise at your job you're going to end
up in a new job and you're going to look
up in 18 months you're going to be debt
free you're going to be making different
kind of money and then the vacation
you'll go on next summer or the summer
after that is going to be something
spectacular right
okay palin how much money do you guys
have in the bank right now
uh we have just that that about two
grand two grand saved
so that scares me to go this camping
trip is going to cost us our entire bank
account yeah that just feels like a
scary place to be i don't think you're
going to be at peace on that trip
so that's part of it and uh you
obviously you read the books you're
about to go full throttle thousand
dollar starter emergency fund and start
attacking this debt can you work
overtime and take extra jobs
i can yeah i could do some side
hospitals yeah i love it
that vacation in front of you
my wife is a stay-at-home mom okay
she works 10 hours a week at the local
church okay cool so this may be one of
those um
shape shifter family moments
where you and your wife go out and
you'll go get dinner you go get
breakfast and you
lay this out and say hey um i read this
book and
i feel a
burden now that uh our family's chained
up to a bunch of different banks and to
car notes into whatever and i want to
work really hard i want us to work
really hard to liberate this family once
and for all and we're going to send a
message to our kids that this is who we
are we're going to send a message to our
community to this is who we are um even
if you got to lose a couple hundred
dollar deposit i think the net i didn't
think to ask that question george you
got two grand man you're gonna come back
with five hundred dollars in the bank
this is gonna be a way more stressful
vacation than it is any sort of
restoration the joy will disappear
quickly that's right that's right
yeah get out of there man
cancel vacation and call us in a couple
of years when you're heading off to a
family cruise my brother
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
if you're a business or hr leader you
know your employees are dealing with a
lot
my employee wellness team smart dollar
just did a study and found out that
after living through one of the toughest
times in history 60 percent of employees
say that their mental health has gotten
worse
half say their mental health keeps them
from doing their job to the best of
their ability
good leaders take their employees mental
wellness seriously because it's good for
your team and your business when your
employees are healthy mentally and it's
the right thing to do
if you call yourself a leader lead
both on the bottom line and in the
hearts and minds of the people that work
for you
so this mental health awareness month
give your employees a way to deal with
their stress and put them on a path to
care for their mental wellness i've got
an anxiety relief checklist that gives
your employees simple steps they can
take to re to relieve their anxiety so
they can start bringing their full
selves to work again
to get my anxiety relief checklist for
your employees go to ramseysolutions.com
anxietychecklist again that's ramsay
solutions dot com
slash anxiety checklist
all right george you got another one for
me so speaking of anxiety john the
student loan crisis is still upon us and
the student loan pause got kicked down
the road again until august 31st you
know what started to remind me of what's
that like when i was in middle school
and i asked this girl out and she was
like maybe
wow and so i just hung in there and then
i come back like a couple weeks later
like hey uh
will you go with me remember that's how
you used to ask it back oh yeah and she
was like oh maybe
i was like okay that's a nice rejection
i end up burning
my seventh grade year
it never happened i never once thought
student loan forgiveness in john's
childhood love life
girls it never happened wow just maybe
me all the way into isolation and
sadness well it reminds me of how many
people have been rejected from the
student loan forgiveness program
it's like my dating life yes well as you
know john we scour the internet for the
latest and greatest videos and uh
there's one that's talking about the
student loan for giving should you pay
off your student loans right now and so
i wanted to play it for you and get your
take you good with that
the last few times you sprung a tick
tock video on me let's do it go for it
roll the beautiful bean footage
hey everyone i saw this headline today
in the news and i just wanted to kind of
talk about it because it is interesting
there's potential to have some sort of
student loan forgiveness on federal
student loan debt here being announced
in the next couple weeks so
you know i myself have actually paid a
little over five thousand dollars this
year with interest rates staying at zero
percent it's allowed me to make a
significant debt in my balance but
you know i might not want to keep paying
that as we get closer to august 31st
especially if there's going to be some
sort of forgiveness
i might
switch my strategy instead of going
right to my student loan balance i'm
going to put that in savings and then
maybe wait and see what what this
announcement is going to be like so stay
tuned we'll keep you up to date but we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments and maybe what some of your
strategies are right now thanks
oh i'll give you some thoughts and
strategies john well hold on
i know did you just hear the there's the
paradox there i there is but can we just
call out most people on tick tock that
you've shown me in the past because i
don't even know how to i would not you
know how to log in you don't give you
access john it's too dangerous you can't
handle it yet a guy seems like a nice
guy yeah i'm not mad at the guy he
should look at nice guys he was
commenting on music
very calming music i really enjoyed that
actually yeah i feel a little bit more
at peace so the article behind him that
you can't see for listening uh was from
bloomberg said don't bother paying off
student loan debt right now advisors say
who are these advisors we don't know why
they want to keep people in debt i have
no idea but what's funny is this
gentleman saying hey i've been paying
off my student loan debt i'm really
feeling the progress as i make a dent in
the principal while the interest is
paused but i might hold off now to see
what happens here and i think he
represents a lot of americans out there
going well i'm not going to pay him off
because what if what if what if yeah
so
george you know i've just we've talked
about this a lot just privately um
my my two thoughts are this um one i am
getting
this is just reality and be disingenuous
to not say this i do have friends of
mine across the country who are in
various fields where they've um
most of my friends are nerds no shock
that have their doctorates and or have
their law degree that have gotten
noticed over the last six months that
hey we've
your loans have been forgiven i can
they're gone
it's a very specific type of loan in a
very specific specific type of program
but i hadn't heard that before so that
actually happened
the other side of it is
it's not wholesale right and this idea
that this is just going to happen and i
think you and i and dave were talking i
think this is going to get punted and
punted and punted and they're going to
have some sort of small low level we'll
take away 5 000 or 10 000 or something
like that with some sort of
right around midterms and try to swing
something back
here's the bigger deal for me
um i grew up didn't have a lot
grown up
my wife grew up uh she didn't have a lot
we had great parents who worked their
butts off for their communities we used
to have a lot of money
and we signed up went to college because
that's what we were supposed to do and
then we kept then my wife went to got
her master's degree i got my master's
degree she got her doctorate i got my
doctorate
and we look up and we had 106 figures in
in student loan debt right
i i knew we had to pay it back but i
didn't i didn't get it and i didn't know
what 30 years at 900 a month meant you
know what i mean
i was 18 and then i was 21.
but
i always had this nagging sense that i
signed my name on a piece of paper and i
told somebody if you help me get through
college i'll pay you back and they did
whoever they happened to be
and i felt a
integrity obligation two poor kids who
are lower middle class kids who got into
it but we still signed our name to this
thing and it's kind of like um like in
the nutrition world right now all of the
conversations are about um like
calories are returning this idea that a
lot of a lot of the problems you see
downstream is because of some fancy diet
but you got to get back to thinking
about calories that's just what the
science is telling us
and
that's very very very true
and if i just eat twinkies every single
day because they're 50 cents
that will cost me at some point in my
life right even if i look at the calorie
density
it's going to cost me and so we can all
clap and cheer that the loans get taken
away
and we just roll another 1.7 trillion
dollars on we will pay for this and it
will
be really rough what we do and so for me
in my house it was about looking in the
mirror saying we did this we said we
were going to pay it off do we know
we're getting to no are we in a mess yes
was it an awful couple years getting
that stuff paid off absolutely
but i walk a little bit taller right and
i'm not sitting there just waiting to
wait and wait and wait and so i love the
first part of that video where he says
man we've had no interest this if
there's ever a moment to burn through
your loans right now pay them off you
don't they're not making any money on it
right yeah that's my that's my take on
it that's a good take and i i as well
walk the stage with 36 000 in student
loan debt not as much as you um and i
just thought i don't remember signing up
for this like i remember the
conversation with my dad was like this
hey dad how are we gonna pay for college
and he's like oh we we got it taken care
of what i didn't know was that meant
we're gonna sign up for student loans
parent plus loans to make sure it's
taken care of and when you're 18 you
don't know you just go to school going
this is fun yeah the college experience
i'm not thinking about money i don't
have a job the number of t-shirts and
dinners
i put on student loans it just is it's
it's
mind-numbing yeah it's maddening so to
that point pay off your student loans
stop waiting for someone to fix your
life because if that's how you look at
student loans that's probably how you
look at other areas of life right why
this is my problem i didn't sign up for
this and at what point do we go i signed
up for all these credit cards and now
i'm in debt they should forgive them
right at what point do we draw the line
and i'll i'll even say this um just
because i was so intimately involved in
this industry um
there are people that were preyed upon
whole groups of people that were
literally targeted they don't know
enough they'll sign up for this we can
get them on the hook
and so
at its core i'm not even opposed to a
like relieving of some of this debt for
people we're seeing some of that happen
now yeah i've i've got no moral issue
because people were trapped not just
even my case right people were preyed
upon i was just made it an
informed decision
but you can't pay you can't forgive the
loans because all these students are
gonna
if we all got our loans forgiven in may
i gotta sign up for the summer term in
june what are we gonna do
and so until you fix the front end of
this deal until you sit down and say all
right how are we gonna fix the college
mess yeah and the cost of college and
the value of college until we have that
conversation
dude this is
it's like drilling a hole in your
bathtub without turning i mean it's like
turn the water off yeah throw the water
off first oh man yeah we talk about this
in borrowed future our documentary that
you're in good stuff there john
appreciate it thanks for
letting me watch yet another ticket
enlightening you you're welcome
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to luis in raleigh north carolina
what's up luis
oh hi guys thank you for taking my call
of course what's up
um so
uh
for starters for starters i'm a handyman
so i make like
32 000 a year
and
you know since like
i don't know i don't know where my
morning is going i don't know how to
budget
and um so
so i was married and um
my wife
as a wife uh last november
what happened
we
can i just tell you brother i'm so sorry
what happened
it's a good um i'm creating cancer oh my
gosh
yeah so how long
well she fighted
for two years you know the first years
you know she did the chemo and radiation
yeah she also had the surgery the
whipple yeah that removed part of the
pancreas
and she was doing good and then you know
she was
yeah we told her she wasn't in remission
for good you know and all the time just
come back but stronger i'm so sorry
i was able to take it yeah i'm so sorry
brother all right so since november and
um
here you find yourself
so what's up yeah
yeah yeah you know i mean it's been it's
been rough but you know
she's with me always and you know she's
i can feel her spirit all the time see
all right so what's up everything
so
so we had a house and now so we and then
selling the house
and so now i got a
so basically yeah so i made 32 000 a
year
um
i always seems like i just spend the
money i don't have no savings
um i had a 2500
cd
for six months
and um that's what i have on my name
but now i have thirty 32 000
dollars that i don't know what to do
with it yeah and then i want to spend it
you know why'd you sell your house man
huh why'd you sell your house
because i think um i didn't qualify for
uh for a mortgage because
well i haven't had a social security
number okay
um
so you make forty two thousand as a
handyman thirty two you make forty two
thirty two thirty
thirty two thirty two maybe more because
i don't keep track of it you know
so you're making 32 but you have 32 from
the house sale
no no
well that's what that was my card
because it was divided in three for
three
divided by three
oh you had to split you had to split up
the the sale of the house the money
y'all made yeah with the kids yes yes
okay so how much money do you have to
your name today
this is 32k
okay and
2500 in a cd
and uh maybe
[Music]
another 2 000
the check is still unclear but without
without 2000 i'm going to pay
two credit cards that both are five
hundred dollars each how much debt do
you have total
that's all um eight hundred dollars 800
on a credit card
yeah yeah um but
well the reason being is because i just
use those credit cards when i get a job
and i just buy the tools you know the
the material for the sure yeah yeah so
then once i get paid i pay the credit
card got it well here's what i would do
if i'm if i'm in your shoes and i woke
up today i would use part of that money
to pay off all your debt and then never
go back into debt i want you to cut up
the card
and switch to a debit card and you can
have your clients pay for the materials
up front i just did this with my
handyman the other day they called me
from lowe's and said hey what's the card
number and that way he never has to get
reimbursed from me so you could try that
route because what i'm worried about
happening is you put this money on the
credit card and then you hope for the
reimbursement but then you spend the
money over here and it becomes a cycle
right right right so hey and you know i
don't even like to take and the reason i
do this is because i don't like to take
money out from from the customers i know
but hey listen luis listen yeah you're
gonna have to make some changes
okay
okay there's some things that you don't
like doing like budgets you don't like
um
yeah i don't even know how to do it
though no no no we're gonna give you the
walk you through we're gonna walk you
through it but here's what i'm saying
at some point and hopefully that's right
now
you're going to stop with any sort of
excuses moving forward and you're just
going to start doing things differently
we're going to give you we're going to
teach you how to budget or teach you the
materials we're going to do that quick
and then we'll send you some some free
resources that we're gonna hook you up
with
you're gonna have to
go talk to somebody
whether that's friends whether that's
community members whether it's a
counselor in your community about
grieving the why the loss of your wife
you're gonna have to choose i want to do
business differently i want to build a
business in this market 32 000 a year
for a handyman no chance brother you
should be making three times that much
and you're worth it you just have to be
intentional about it so do i have your
commitment before we get down this road
because if not we can just take the next
call are you no no no are you willing to
do things differently
yes i do all right we got you good so
once we pay off this credit card we say
no more to credit cards and we don't
touch debt ever again and you ask me
what's the best way to spend the 32 000
the best way is to not spend it this
part of this is gonna become your
emergency fund
and so look at what six months of
expenses looks like for you are you
renting right now
um all my spencer's
on this new place i'm leaving it's gonna
be 800
800 a month total for your expenses
yeah yeah where are you living yeah
um
uh her cousin uh had a house that need
to be fixed
so we came into agreement while i'm
living there i'm gonna fix it so
is it a safe place to live is it a
livable condition
uh it's now i mean i've been working on
it but yeah yes it's literal yeah okay
so i'm gonna call your emergency fund 7
500 just to be safe because one thing
goes out hvac you name it things can add
up real quick
so if we took out 7 500 out of that
money we paid off the credit card that
probably leaves you with a little over
20 000 correct
right right okay we're going to start
using this to start building your life
because i'm guessing you have nothing
invested
you said you had nothing saved so we've
got to start working on
luis and how are the future
right
what was that you have a truck like a
work truck
yeah i got a pico truck and i have
another car so i've had two cars but my
pickle truck is all okay and uh okay you
know it's just it's just it's just a job
truck right okay all right cool uh yes
yes okay so on the budgeting side we're
gonna gift you ramsay plus which
includes every dollar premium that's our
budgeting tool that you can use on your
phone you can do this online it's really
easy to set up your budget and what
you're going to do is list out your
income on one side and your expenses
underneath that and i want that to equal
zero so if you make let's say three
thousand dollars a month i want you to
give every single one of those three
thousand dollars a name a job so it's
going towards something it may be going
towards savings it may be going towards
upgrading the truck eventually it may be
going towards some basic expenses do you
have a good insurance in place in all
areas of your life health insurance auto
insurance
okay i want you to get health insurance
today insurance
okay that's very very important because
medical bills will bankrupt you if
you're not careful you get hurt on the
job what's going to happen how are you
going to pay for those medical bills
with no insurance
right so get that in place um hang on
the line austin's going to pick up we're
going to make sure that he gets you
plugged into ramsey plus as part of that
financial peace university is included i
want you to watch all nine lessons of
that because it's gonna give you a
baseline education on money and i think
that's gonna equip you and give you some
confidence some freedom some control
over your situation because right now
you just feel lost don't you you feel
like i have no clue what to do next
right right and i mean i make i make
good money and uh you know i have time i
have more time to make more money if i
want to you know
i think you need to charge more for sure
what are you charging an hourly rate
uh
per job and sometimes you have an hour
what do you turn in for an hour
for our 45
let's up it up it 50 60 75 people are
going to be willing to pay that it's so
hard to find good hard-working reliable
people these days and hey listen we're
also going to send you uh
uh
two books
okay
actually you know we're gonna send you
three books we're already sitting right
here so we're gonna send you a copy of
total money makeover
i'm gonna send you a copy of the entree
leadership book to teach you how to run
a small business and i'm gonna send you
my new book own your past change your
future about dealing with the traumas
that have happened and then asking that
one scary question what do i do now this
book's gonna walk you through how to be
well my brother louise we just we're
giving you everything we got
it's up to you to put this stuff into
action thank you so much it's one hour
in the books we'll be right back on the
ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john delony co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money
scary scary times give us a shout at
eight eight two five five two two five
we're here to talk common sense and put
some perspective and some peace and some
whoo back into your life triple eight
eight two five five two two five i'm
john dalone joined here by my good
friend george campbell and we're taking
your calls just about everything let's
go out to dalen in boise back to boise
one of my favorite places what's up
dalen
hey how you doing good my brother what's
up
hey so before i actually uh
say my question i just want to say that
i'm very excited and happy that i dm'd
both you and george on instagram and got
a response from both of you so i feel
like a rock star so that was actually uh
stalin just want you to yeah hey it
actually is us and here's my thought if
somebody takes a moment to reach out and
say hey i appreciate you it's pretty
lame for me not to say hey i'm grateful
for that because those little notes um
we get a lot of people drinking the
hatred and
those little notes are
just a little bit of coal to help the
train get down the track a little bit
further so i'm grateful for you man
thanks for reaching out so what's up
perfect i'm i'm glad to hear it um so my
question is uh i want to buy a car for
my sister-in-law because she's
graduating high school tomorrow she's
walking tomorrow um and i'm not aiming
to buy this anytime soon so to say but
within the next i guess few months
um but i'm just wondering since it is a
pretty big purchase you know depending
how much i decide to spend on it
what percentage of my savings and or net
worth should i put into that investment
i mean put into that car knowing that
it's not for my pleasure
hmm
well give us a little bit of your
financial picture
yeah so i make currently about 90 000 a
year in net so in take home
um
i'm
on track to be making 120 125 this year
i got quite the raise at work so that's
good quite the promotion um
and i have about 160 000 in liquid cash
in my savings and then i have just you
know
i guess you can say 5000 or less in my
checking um
but anyways
a debt free yes do you own a home
um yes i do is it paid for you got a
mortgage
so i have a mortgage okay how much
the mortgage is about 1800
how much do you owe in the house
oh
i think i owe about
i would say
280 000 probably
why do you have 160 thousand dollars in
cash
and 280 000 yeah
i guess you're right yeah
i want you to be generous i'm just i'm
just trying to figure out where you're
at and where she's at how much are you
wanting to spend on this car for her and
what's the heart behind it
so um it's just to give her a good jump
starting live so she has a good car in
college i guess um and i'm only thinking
to spend
uh
probably no more than twelve thousand
okay
what is she i mean when i was in college
i was under no illusion that i had to
drive a nice car does she have a car
currently
she does not oh so no vehicle right now
no vehicle do you know her financial
situation what's your relationship with
your sister-in-law
uh
so they're really close my wife and
sister-in-law are really close um
and you know we love her to death of
course
we're family so
i don't know they almost want to
show off a little bit but not show off
you know so so that that was going to be
my my question here is is the car
something that she has need needs and
that you all have circled up
or and this is the pot talking to the
kettle here man
are you wanting to buy a car a because
you can you're doing really well
but you also like going a little bit
over the top to show and like look at
this i'm pretty generous guy
because if you buy a gift for somebody
to show them how great you are you've
completely wasted that gift
if you buy somebody a gift to bless them
and to give them a little bit more peace
to make bring them joy or laughter or
kindness or whatever
meet a need
for them
man that's a whole other ball game right
and so i don't know that there's such
thing as a percentage um george off top
yeah you got 160 grand cash buying a 10
000 car for somebody yeah it's not going
to tank you still hit your financial
goals now part of that's your emergency
fund right
right okay so there's the lesson there
i'm just looking at percentages hey if
you're going to drain your entire
savings account to do this that's not
going to be a blessing to you and so the
way i look at it is if i did this
anonymously would it still feel just as
good
that's a hard question to ask yourself
yeah
if you went or if a car just showed up
on her driveway she had no clue it was
for me would i still have the same
amount of joy
or get three or four other family
members who can pitch in 25 bucks or a
hundred bucks or a thousand bucks or a
thousand bucks and you put everybody's
name on it as though it came from
everybody equally
okay even though you put the and here's
here's the exercise
the exercise is
i'm not giving somebody something to
puff my chest out i'm giving something
to somebody sacrificially to help them
out and if you do this here's the deal
so george tell me if i'm if i'm wrong
here
we'll sign off on it you buy her a 10 or
12 000 car i think it's a beautiful gift
i think that's i mean of course it's
going to be a blessing to her
and you pull out 40 or 50 grand for your
emergency fund the other 100 000 bucks
goes on your mortgage that same day is
that fair
that's fair yeah i'm i'm all for it
let's knock this thing out what does
your wife think about this command it's
her sister
is she all for this
yeah she's all for it um you know her
and i wanted to
get her an iphone but she already bought
an iphone herself um what are her
your sister-in-law what is her
relationship with money do you know
anything about her money habits is she
bad with money is she great with money
so
she's more of a spender than a saver but
i don't know how much she spends and how
much she saves yeah my my only worry on
her side is is this almost enabling
where she goes sweet i can keep being an
idiot with money because now i don't
have to worry about saving up for a car
and she doesn't get the satisfaction the
growth of having to save up and pay cash
for that car and now she drives it
differently because of that
that's very true or maybe you get this
car and you sit down and say we're going
to buy you a car but you have to commit
to going to college debt-free
okay yeah okay i'm going to bless you
but you're going to this is going to
come with some strength so that's going
to be the opposite of what we're talking
about we're not giving it away um
uh we're not giving this thing away
anonymously but we're giving this thing
with a set of this i'm setting you up to
go make good in the world but here's
what making goods gonna look like and if
you take this great but you're gonna be
committing to
four years of this car is going to help
you get from campus to your job and then
to your second job because we're going
to get through this thing debt-free yeah
i want you to help her with her life and
not just college and so it's a little
bit of the teach amanda fish approach
where you go i want to help her have
these money principles that will guide
her for life and not just give her a
one-time gift and allow her to continue
to outspend her income
in the future is that fair
yeah that's fair yeah thank you so much
all right love your heart on this man
yeah so to think think broadly giving
is for someone else and it always feels
good when you do it and always the best
thing you can do with money is give it
away it's one of my yeah it's one of the
greatest things in the world we'll be
right back on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go out to zach in huntsville texas
what's up zack how we doing
oh well uh first off i gave some thanks
because about two months ago i called
you and uh dave
was very very angry about a divorce and
you guys pointed that out and not gonna
lie i was actually shocked when i heard
the call
later when the episode played and you
guys were right i followed some of your
advice and i've calmed myself down quite
a bit
so with that in mind i'm calling back to
reiterate real quick
can i just tell you
one of the hardest
drugs in the planet to get off of is the
drug of anger
and the fact that you
were able to exhale and say i don't want
to die young i don't want to burn the
people around me out i'm worth more than
that and you're putting in the work
to bring all that down
dude thank you like that's an
inspiration to millions and millions and
millions of raged out angry men so thank
you for that that's hard man what you're
doing is hard and i'm proud of you
eddie appreciate that sir so what's up
man um
so now that i'm less angry and have a
little more clear ahead considering
i was going to try to get what i had
called that day for which is
i need a little bit of budgeting advice
on how to budget on a fluctuating income
for the month
and
how to possibly get some accountability
because like i mentioned the last time i
drive a truck for a living and
i'm trying to figure out how to get
accountability for the days where my
depression and
issues with the divorce still hurting
and stuff get to the point where i just
want to say screw the budget and go
spend some money so that i have a little
bit of
can have a little bit of fun or do
something good
absolutely by myself all right so george
is going to walk through the budgeting
and we'll circle back at the end there
for
the depression and control stuff go
ahead so zach what's the range of your
income being a regular give me a range
um i make the uh i make on the high set
up
apologies
if this takes a few minutes my stutter's
acting up today oh good good man
i make
between 15
and
2 grand a paycheck each week sometimes
if the freight's not great it will go
lower like this week i got 700 bucks
because i didn't run very much last week
and are you able to make all your
expenses right now are you covering all
your bills just fine
i'm covering all the bills
and the couple of problems i've run into
is i've been splitting the bills up like
budget saying that
this week i'm gonna do
like this week i paid my phone bill and
i paid for a dentist appointment that's
coming up
and then like next week i'm going to pay
[Music]
uh half of my rent
and something like that i'm not going to
go throw the bills because i can't run
off the top of my head but but you're
saying you're barely keeping up with
what's happening next week and next week
and hoping the check hits and it's
enough
uh kinda and then i end up nickel and
diming myself out whenever the uh
miscellaneous things that need done at
the house come up i got roommates that
i'm
they're helping me take care of my house
while i'm on the road and i am trying to
control that and
wondering about a budgeting strategy so
that i don't keep nickel and diming
myself out of the rest of my paycheck by
accident because we're trying to save up
to move okay so and also i got the
divorce and i may need a lawyer i'm not
sure yet
so when it comes to this budget what i
want you to do is you know your baseline
income you know on a really bad month it
may be 1500 bucks so let's base it off
of that then we're going to list out the
a1 things that you know you need to
cover so that's going to be your four
walls food utilities shelter
transportation so list out those
expenses and you know if we get 700 we
know it's going to get covered first
we're going to keep the roof over our
heads we're going to put food on the
table put gas in the car beyond that
then you go down the list of priorities
and go okay after that it's going to be
clothing after that it might be the
netflix subscription whatever's on that
list and so whatever money comes in
you've already allocated towards those
priorities so that's the way to do it
with a regular income i'm going to gift
you every dollar how are you budgeting
right now
i'm you um uh
uh i i appreciate the gift i already
have a ramsey plus subscription oh great
great i am
using it somebody there can help me i'm
having trouble getting my bank to
connect to it i don't know why
absolutely jump onto the contact page on
ramseyplus and we also have financial
coaching available for you and they can
walk you through what that looks like
with your specific budget and you can uh
yeah so stay on the line and aj will
walk you through that stuff but
uh in the financial coaching we'll hook
you up with that as well um you can ask
very specific detail here's my budget
and here's my situation and they'll walk
you through that okay
um okay i greatly appreciate that guys
that is really actually going to help me
a lot more oh you bet and here's what i
want you to do before you go to bed
tonight i want you to get a sharpie and
i want you to write a small note that
says the following words
don't forget to remember
and i want you to put that sign on your
fridge
and i want you to put that sign on your
steering wheel on your truck
don't forget to remember
and this particular sentence has
transformed my life
because like you i'm kind of a hot head
and i'm always running and gunning and
gunning and running
and
we could sit down and talk about all the
diagnostics we have
but at the end of the day
i get into my truck to go home and i
don't i literally don't even process the
number of cans and trash and shirts that
i've just thrown in there
and as i'm getting out of my car i
remember the phrase don't forget to
remember
how good it feels to get back into a
clean car on the way to work
and i'll stop and then i will look and
say okay this has to get taken care of
and for you
don't forget to remember how good it
feels to wake up in the morning when you
haven't had a fourth or fifth drink or a
second or third
or when you haven't had two frozen
pizzas and slept on the couch
don't forget to remember how good it
feels next week when you still have 350
bucks in your account
and all we're doing is beginning to
train our brains slowly
to pause between that moment of anger
that moment of frustration and then
whatever coping strategy we're going to
come up with next some people drink some
people take a swing at somebody in a bar
some people buy a bunch of crap some
people what fill in the blank they call
some girl they shouldn't call
everybody's got their the things that
they use to wallpaper and duct tape over
their hurt all i want folks to do is to
have a gap
here's the second thing you have to
get other men in your life that you go
hang out with
period whether you go bowling you'll go
fishing you'll play play golf for god's
sake and i if you know how i think about
golf that's totally i've seen john golf
and i don't want to see it it's not
great because i hate it but go golf do
something
with other men
why because you need friends you need
community you got to have connection and
here's the third thing
you do need a lawyer
okay
you've been avoiding it because the the
this whole process is hard and it's
scary and that makes it really real
once that she filed papers on you
neither of us have filed yet i'm trying
to navigate the fact that she
skips states and
i'm going to be honest the only reason i
debated the lawyers because we don't
have assets to just decide between the
only thing that i really want to keep is
the dog and that's silly because she
won't take care of her and listen take
care of while she was married and what
an attorney will help you with divorce
an attorney will help you and it is
expensive it is
but you and you don't have assets now
but you might later
and what you want to do is close every
loop every uh put a period at the end of
every sentence
so that you don't get a house and
get remarried and have two kids and have
a couple of cars and suddenly you bought
a second and third truck with cash and
you've got a little bit of an operation
running here and you're doing really
great
and then one of these these sentences
that you didn't tie up with an attorney
comes back and your ex comes back and
asks for some stuff that is supposedly
hers and that could be a mess
so get an attorney pay the money say you
don't have any assets you're just
looking for some help in the proceedings
to put some periods at the end of these
sentences so hang on the line we're
gonna hook you up with this stuff don't
hang up here and my brother i'm proud of
you
i'm proud of you you're making these
tiny grinding little steps towards being
well towards getting your feet back
underneath you to fixing your business
to get control your money it's what we
all have to do i'm proud of you keep
going keep going we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
george we i just man i got in last night
from
a week in orlando started with the event
that you and i and the rest of the gang
did oh yeah well eventually you've been
on the road for like three weeks it
feels like i've been out yeah i'm tired
man um but that building both of it was
crazy it was awesome uh fantastic
everybody came out in orlando and then
we hung around for entree summit
i i've never seen anything like it
here's a couple of things that made
andre's summit so great i mean there was
like jamie william kerna and
jay leno and jocko and
jade simmons and will gudera here's what
was so rad
was normally you go to these events and
as a speaker you know this you're
backstage in the green room and there's
a tv on that has the speakers speaking
but everybody's like going over their
notes or everybody chatting laughing
playing dominoes whatever dude people
were glued it was cool to see the best
of the best of the best getting off
stage and running either back into the
audience to watch the next speaker or
to
run back and get and pull us a chair up
in front of the screens to watch the
next one right so you got pat lincion
and he gets right off stage and the next
person's like okay i gotta watch the
next guy right
and it was incredible
to see
the people and that you and i look up to
who if quote unquote made it and they
are still
iron sharpens iron lifelong learners can
i do this better can i even oh that was
a good one i'm going to write that down
and um man i've never heard will gadara
speak i've never heard jade simmons
speak
it was next level yeah our leadership
team was back here watching the live
stream and it was just as incredible i'm
sure the in-room energy was electric and
i love what i love to that point is if
you watch dave ramsey he's in the crowd
taking more notes than almost anyone's
on every speaker that's right and it's
like that's dave ramsey he doesn't need
to hear he's taking notes on every one
of them yeah and he's soaking it all in
and so i love the mutual respect that
you all have for each other in that room
i mean a lot of brilliant minds
a lot of successful people gathered in
one place even the business owners in
the crowd every time i'd be at summit
i'm like these people are more
successful than i am exactly i'm happy
to be in the room with them yeah it was
something else and also you and i were
talking off air
man it was a uh
it's sobering
what the
american business women and american
businessmen are going through right now
um there's 3 000 people in that room and
but the energy was off the chart
everybody's excited and uh
it was heavy
what people are
facing right they can't afford to hire
new people because it's so expensive or
they just can't find them we went for
breakfast this morning me and my family
and it was a two and a half hour event
just to run down the street and go to
breakfast together i got back in town
last night we went to breakfast just as
a family this morning just because
there's no there's no workers right and
you got these trucking companies and
plumbing companies and electric
electricians
who can't afford to get to and from jobs
because the gas is so expensive and so
they're working 90 hours a week they're
trying to be good moms they're trying to
be good dads they're trying and it's
just they found themselves in a vortex
of hell and it's hard
um and so it's cool just to get with
people in a room they could all exhale
and say i'm going through it too but
bravo to the entree team here was just
some next level i was the best i've
heard dave speak the whole it was on
yeah it was something else and it was uh
you and i were talking you mentioned
that
sometimes you're backstage you know
there's there's it feels like there's a
limited amount of pie right and like oh
if that guy does really good on his that
means i have to do worse then that means
he took something from it
man it was a spirit of
oh you did that good that's so great i'm
gonna it was everybody was there was
there was an important
amount of pie back there was just
something else so close to everybody um
and if you missed it
you better be at the next get your
tickets it's in nashville next year it's
gonna be a hometown for us and uh man
you would be out of your mind to miss
that if you're a business um if you're
in a leadership position or want to be
this is the event for you golly it was
incredible just world class glad you
made it back safe with the team yeah i
again i was asking you all like i didn't
i don't know i thought it was wednesday
but it's thursday john doesn't know
where he is right now that's exactly
this is the doctor john dillon it might
be let's go to william in greenville
south carolina what's up william
hey dr john um
absolutely love the new book thank you
george
yeah you're welcome um george i got a
question for you i've been scouring tick
tock and i couldn't find it
so i figured i'd bring it down oh
william do not get funny because you're
too smart
if you're too you're too smart for tick
tock william
what's going on with you
all right so i just went up yesterday
and picked up my second child from
college and i realized
we've got extra money in her 529 we've
also got extra money in my older
daughter
her 529
and i still have a son that's a
sophomore in college and he is going to
have some extra money in his and i
started thinking about it and i was like
you know
everybody says wait don't you know save
this money because they might and two of
them are going to grad school but we'll
be fine with that um
but why why wouldn't i
continue to fund
these 529s i was thinking you know i
should still continue to put money in
here even though i know they're not
going to use them because
by the time they get grown up and have
children that are ready to go to college
i can give them
i can skip my
my children's generation give them to
them
and they will have had an
extra round of compounding
so i'll have a lot more money
and i've talked to a couple of i've
talked to two different financial
advisors about them and one of them was
like yeah that's not a bad idea the
other one was like
that's a terrible idea to tie up that
amount of money for that amount of time
and i was just calling
to see
what you thought about it because i it
seems to me i should be able to with a
little bit more money
super fund by the time they're old
enough
my grandchildren
that's cool man that's leaving a legacy
i don't i don't think your financial
advisor is thinking that way i think
they're thinking well that's less money
for me he's not investing with me
william hey
just dude you're thinking generationally
and that's how wealth gets good man are
you on track for retirement william
yes yeah okay how old are you
53 what's your net worth
about 20. golly 20 million
yeah
[Laughter]
dude he just that's great eyeballs just
fell out of my head man dude
you do what you want
you should be giving us advice
how did you get to 20 million dollars at
53 just curious
i have a great job i have a lot of um i
have a great job but i don't got 20
million dollars
well
a very well-funded job and
from the time i
started working i saved my money and i
now have several paid for warehouses
that
are
paying rent through the roof and um just
very lucky
wow very fortunate work worked very hard
but but lucky as well well you're
inspiring man the truth is you can
cashflow college for the next three
generations you don't even have to worry
about 529. now it's a great tax
advantage strategy to save for college
but the truth is and dave ramsey would
tell you this he'd go people like you
they're able to cash flow if there's not
enough and so clearly there's going to
be an abundance in the 529s you're okay
with that you can change the beneficiary
to the grandkid if there's money left
over there's a lot of things you can do
with that money
so i'm all good with that and again you
don't know what the kids are going to be
doing with grad school and man they've
got options when you've got all that
money in 529s and a dad like you who can
cash flow and help them go to school
debt free here's here's what i like
about it william
is um
it protects the investment
that you have in your heart and mind
this gift that you want to go towards
college
it it seems to be a pretty clean way to
make sure this money is used for
educational expenses
right well john it's funny you say that
because one of the like one of the one
of the financial advisors told me he
said
why don't you just pay them out of your
brokerage accounts
why don't you if you want to do that why
don't you just why don't you just pay
them out of your brokerage accounts and
i'm telling them i'm saying look i can
put this over here in this little bucket
and forget about it forever i don't ever
have to think about it again that's
right it's free it is tax free and if
you get hit by a bus will you exactly
and it grows tax-free it's it's
basically an ira for my grandchildren
that haven't been born yet for them to
go to college i think you should be his
financial advisor
yes you need to call him and say you're
willing to take his business but the fee
is going to be high i think you're
exactly right and
this is a way to say hey we took care of
your educational expenses whatever
college may look different in 20 years
but
investing in education is always going
to be a good way to use i want to be
william when i grow up
william you have set the bar my brother
it's an honor to talk to you yeah i'd
i'd put some money in that take care of
generations to come we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well folks it's been proven over and
over again you can crush your financial
personal and professional goals whether
you want to pay off debt land that dream
job or build better relationships you
can make it happen and we're putting our
number one best-selling books and tools
in the ramsey 10 sale to give you the
proven plan on how to knock out those
goals so if you have money goals you're
trying to hit if you want to learn how
to get out of debt and build wealth you
can do that with the total money
makeover or rachel's book know yourself
know your money just 10 bucks each and
as you're making summer plans you can
have some fun and meaningful
conversations with the people you care
about with my friend dr john deloni's
questions for humans couples edition or
friends edition and if you've got a high
school grad and you want to give them a
gift that will help them escape the trap
of student loan debt pick up the
graduate survival guide or our brand new
high school gift pack
there is something for everyone in the
sale and i know 10 bucks doesn't get you
much anymore but it does uh here at
ramsey solutions with the 10 sale a lot
of value for your money these books and
tools will help you make a plan today to
crush your goals and right now they're
up to 67 percent off so go shop the
ramsay ten dollar sale at
ramseysolutions.com
before the sale ends dude ten dollars of
gas will get you a quarter tank it's
amazing that's sad i mean a quarter
gallon i mean
i saw a video it went up to two hundred
dollars
in california it was like a 20 you know
they were filling up 26 27 gallons at
six bucks a gallon oh wow that hurts my
brain 200
nope
i'm really missing the prius that i
crashed into the wall
oh gosh that's a story for another time
have you shared that on air that's a
really expensive breathing exercise now
with gas prices man it's a hilarious now
knowing you're safe it's a hilarious
story but man i wish i had that now
instead of that
truck out there yeah all right let's go
to matt in hartford what's up brother
matthew how are you doing today good my
man what's up
thank you for taking my call first of
all uh so i've got a bit of a difficult
financial situation i'm very fortunate
to be in this position but i've still
kind of got a lot of expenses piling up
and i'm kind of just worried about how
that's what the best way is to navigate
it
so
i was able to purchase a house in cash
it's been a dream of mine for many years
and i saved up for many years and i was
also
in a very fortunate position to be
gifted with some of money from my family
as well and all that together meant that
i was able to buy a house in cash but
the problem
that i'm running into now is that i have
a very large amount of repairs that
needs to get done with the property and
i have a very limited amount of cash
left after spending all of it on buying
the house and i'm just wondering about
the best way to potentially cash flows
in these repairs and if my income is
going to be enough to do that and if i
might need to get a second job
potentially
to in order to help pay for some of it
okay so what's your income
so i just got a new job and it'll be 44
000 a year
and how much money do you have in the
bank
liquid right now i have about 11 11 000
in cash i just wrote a check for 6 800
bucks so when that clears i i have
11 grand left in cash okay and is that
your emergency fund at that point or
part of it yes so we gotta build my
emergency fund
okay so what i want you to do is
separate out your emergency fund from
the home repair fund because i'm worried
that they become two in one and all of a
sudden you are very very broke
yeah that's what i'm worried about too
how what's the urgency of these repairs
can you do them over the next six months
i mean is it a safe place to live
i'm i'm hoping that i can i think i can
but i don't 100 know like there's some
things i need urgently addressing like i
just wrote a check for 600 bucks for
asbestos removal that was urgent i had
to get that done
um
and i've got electrical problems and
i've got an electrician coming next week
to
hopefully sort out that but i'm guessing
it's going to be i don't know exactly
how much it's going to cost people i've
estimated a few thousand because the
amount of electric work that needs to
get done is expensive half the lights in
my place don't work was this a
fixer-upper yeah why'd you buy this
house man did you get an inspection or
appraisal on it
i know i didn't get it i
my realtor advised me to weigh the
inspection because of the market that
we're in with the real estate market
being what it is i was fortunate i
didn't have to pay over asking price i
can't exactly asking oh you're paying
for it you're not fortunate brother
you're paying
your real estate agent encouraged you
because they got the fee
man
how much did you pay for this house
200 000.
well the good news is you don't have a
mortgage and so you have more margin in
your income i would get the side job in
order at least until the repairs are
done and it's in good living condition
have you
matt have you sat down and written out
all of the repairs you're going to need
i i have
i have a pretty extensive list
there are some things that i don't know
for sure exactly when they need to get
done for instance i know i need a roof
done but i was told that i might have up
to a year
before i really need to need to get it
done like i was told it wasn't it's not
something i need to get them tomorrow
if i'm you here's what i would do this
is me just telling you exactly what i
would do if i'm in your shoes
i would pay the money and i would um go
get an inspect a home inspection and
have somebody a professional walk
through it from from nose to tail it'll
cost you a few hundred bucks yes and
it's gonna be money well well spent
and they're gonna give you a list a 20
or 30 page document with photos and say
here's everything that would make the
house just able to be sold
and then you can ask the inspector they
walk through it with you as part of this
and say what has to be done right now
and that way it's that will give you
some peace because you don't even know
how big of an elephant you're trying to
eat right now
you're just scarfing down every little
bit that you can and what you're gonna
do is like george said you're gonna end
up broke and you're gonna end up fixing
one thing and you should have spent the
money over here so dude you need a plan
back up slow down you i me i'm real
tempted to tell him george to sell the
house because dude this could be a force
we don't know how much of a money put
this thousand dollar hole i would start
with the inspection and then the
inspector goes dude this you're looking
at a hundred grand to get i mean who
knows if you need a new roof the
foundation's messed up the asbestos i
mean it keeps adding up right this
thing's a loss so i would get that thing
i would get an inspection done they're
going to give you a big report and you
walk through with them the inspectors
that i've worked at in the past are
they're just great and they work for you
so they're going to tell you the truth
and i'd get that done asap man
and then yeah you're going to have
you're going to know what kind of hole
you've dug and then that's going to
dictate what kind of side job you need
to get or two side jobs or three side
jobs but please remember what george
said do not
just dump all of your quote unquote
extra money that's not being used for
bills into the same pot you've got to
have an emergency fund that sits over
here for true emergencies when that roof
caves in on you right and you got to go
get that thing fixed yeah this house is
very quickly turning from a blessing
into a curse that's right and i'm i'm
proud of him for saving up the money and
of course there's some family money that
came in there help him do this with cash
which is amazing but a lot of people
right now john are making some bad
decisions when it comes to housing
because of fear that's right and because
agreed they're going well now's the time
if i don't do it now i'll never do it
and my realtor said my realtor said
don't do anything you're not comfortable
with that's right and if you're not
comfortable with it get a new realtor
but do not wave inspections and
appraisals because you end up in a
situation like this even with no
mortgage he's stressed out to his
eyeballs that's right um
i mean i just personally i had helms
inspected when we're trying to buy
nashville you know it's like trying to
buy nashville and i walked away from a
few deals because i didn't know once we
put a shovel in the ground i don't know
what that step is going to actually the
damage you know it's going to give you 4
000 to 60. well that's a big margin
right and so i walked away from a few
deals and to my realtor was hard it was
frustrating
but dude i'm not gonna buy a home i'm
not gonna buy that big of an investment
without somebody telling me what i'm
what i'm it's the biggest purchase of
your life this is not the time to go
yeah we'll buy it sight unseen as is i'm
sure it'll be fine cool man yeah cause
it man those those repairs
could be a mess let me ask you this
george so um
let's
back up and say this guy could do this
over
principle-wise financially
if he instead of putting um and i don't
remember exactly what he said how much
he uh how much did he say he got in the
it was 200 grand so he paid cash okay
if he had mortgaged 125 of that i mean
i'm sorry he had mortgage 75 of that put
125 down and then kept 75 000 for
potential repairs and then once that
smoke clears to put the rest of that
money is that yeah i like that plan
because then you're putting 75 down on
this house
and that you you leave yourself some
cash to live with right well if you're
buying a house that you don't know much
about because you didn't get an
inspection yeah i'm gonna assume there's
some problems i need to fix and
therefore i need to have the funds to
make sure i can fix that yeah and you
want to talk about
cash reserve on top of that gonna sell
you something and they say you're not
allowed to look and see if it actually
works or not that should be a big red
flag maybe i shouldn't buy that yeah if
i'm buying a car from a stranger i'm
going i'm gonna get this thing inspected
yes that's a car not a house not a house
that's right so i treat it the same way
excellent man well hey thank you so much
everybody for calling george great job
people and the folks in the booth the
peeps in the booth thank you all so so
much
and i'm john doloni listen be kind to
one another
no amount of worrying is going to bring
gas prices down it's time for us to get
into
action we'll be right back on the ramsay
show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your money
your debt
your successes and your life your
relationships your mental health your
work all of it right here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five i'm john dalony joined here
by my good friend george campbell and we
are taking your calls on just about
everything so give us a shout
uh let's go out to new york how about
that let's go to new york and talk to
vicky what's up vicky
hi how are you john outstanding how are
you
i'm awesome it's an absolute pleasure to
talk to you i listen to dave and you and
george every day on the way to work and
on the way home from work so
we're so grateful
i have two things i need to confirm with
you before i ask my question all right
the first thing is um at full retirement
age which for me will be 66 in eight
months and my husband 66 and six months
there is no limit to the amount of
income you can make without affecting
your social security is that correct
i think so you probably you've studied
this more than i have
okay
i think that's correct
the other thing i wanted to ask was
money that's put into roth iras the
deposits are done with after
tax income correct yes
okay and any money that's in those
accounts grows
tax-free and then when you start to
withdraw it the principle and the
interest is tax free
yes the whole thing when you withdraw
every bit of withdrawal
it just goes into your pocket
okay so here comes my question so my
husband and i have about 450 000 in
traditional iras that were
rolled over
from company 401k plans from previous
jobs so that is all sitting in a
traditional ira and our income currently
right now is about 125 000 a year which
is slowly going down because my husband
is semi-retired
by my best calculations are income in
retirement between
a teaching pension social security and
small part-time jobs is going to be
about the same as it is right now right
so i was wondering
i'm hopefully that's where it will be in
a few years
but my question was is would it be worth
our while now to start slowly taking
some of that money out of a 401k i'm
sorry out of the traditional ira
take the tax hit
and then put it into a roth ira which it
could grow
you know exponentially without having to
pay taxes on it
well i wouldn't say that just as an
overall plan that's the right move
because as you mentioned there's big tax
implications there and it's you know six
dozen half the other whatever the saying
is but
whatever that is
but you're gonna pay taxes on the
traditional side if you take it out like
you're mentioning
or you're gonna pay a big tax bill to
turn it into tax-free growth
either way and so i'd rather you start
from here
so i would you're saying should i take
out a little bit of money and convert it
to the roth portion yes
over the next four to five years because
we won't we hopefully won't have to even
dip into this until there's mandatory
withdrawals at seven i think it's seven
yeah okay uh
so
you're taking you're thinking about
cashing out your tr your traditionals
early paying the penalty plus the tax to
roll
penalties at their age
well i don't think there are penalties
my husband is 65.
okay here's the thing i just met with
one of our smartvestor pros um
two days ago and we were talking about
this exact situation
and there's actually a strategy they use
where it's smart to have some on the
traditional side and some on the roth
side do you have a roth portion as well
uh we do not have a roth no so how much
do you have total in retirement outside
of pensions and social security is it
this 450
it's this it's
000 in traditional ira a house that's
worth about 375 we have about 75 left in
a mortgage and about 35 000 sitting in
um
in standard savings accounts and that's
kind of your emergency fund
yes okay that is my emergency fund do
you guys have a financial advisor
currently
yes we actually do we have somebody that
we've used for years but we don't see
him until
november december and i'm starting to
think about this because it's getting
well once a year okay i would date
accounts i would definitely see him next
week see him next week and go hey what's
the best move here because we can't get
into all the nitty gritty details of
this and i don't want to steer you in
the wrong direction but my gut says this
is not a wise move to all of a sudden
convert this into roth maybe a portion
at a time but it may be wise to use some
of this traditional money use it as
income coming in and pay the tax bill as
that happens as taxes ordinary income
well we would never take the whole thing
and convert it because we don't have
that kind of money to pay the taxes but
the thought that it can grow
tax-free when we want to take it out
even if we took a small chunk twenty
thousand dollars or thirty thousand
dollars a year transit or transferred it
over to a roth would that be worth our
while
my gut tells me the math isn't going to
work there yeah i think when you're when
you're in your 20s or 30s it makes sense
to convert it and let that money grow
for a long period of time but as you're
in the retirement age this is where i go
they're going to run some numbers on
both sides and show you on paper uh
which one makes more sense and my gut
says i could be wrong but my gut says
leaving it in traditional side and just
pulling that money out and paying the
taxes on it as you go is going to be
your best bet and vicki i would tell you
this um
you are
looking at
the potential for growth so i'm going to
take this hit here and you're leaving
one giant variable untouched on the
table
and that is the great a great gift you
can give yourself heading in retirement
is no debt liabilities whatsoever
and you still owe 75 on your mortgage
but the goal here is is that when we do
retire there will be a move to a cheaper
part of the united states new york is
not kind to its um retirees
which whatever we walk away from with
this house is what we're going to put
into a house with no mortgage so you're
going to pay cash
yes correct
could you use your future cash flow to
pay off the mortgage
as you guys head into retirement
um the goal is is that the house will be
paid for by the time we retire that we
will not have a mortgage here okay
that's good then to get that knocked out
of the way i george i hear a lot of
people talk about i'm gonna do this i
want this investment strategy i want
this i want this and they're heading
into retirement they got 200 000 or 100
000.75 left on their mortgage
and man anything goes sideways there
um and they lose this or the market
crashes or their returns are lower they
think they're going to be
that house payment stays the same every
month oh yeah you get that sucker off
the table get rid of that fixed expense
that's exactly and i like man talking to
our smartvestor pro i was just like i
was first of all nerding out with him
but it was so helpful to go oh these
guys don't just hit a button and invest
and take your money that's not what this
is about a good financial advisor is a
coach that looks at your entire money
picture and helps you be really
strategic when it comes to taxes and
estate planning and all the pieces of
your puzzle to make sure you do the
right thing i love that man hey we'll be
right back on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight
two five five two two five my brain
stopped there for a second triple eight
eight two five five two two five george
looks like a glitch in the matrix it was
man my uh
[Music]
yeah i'm running on fumes i looked over
and i thought oh my gosh he is a robot
yeah my brain stopped wow just learning
how well in my possession john i've got
your questions for humans conversation
cards uh friends edition i didn't go
with couples edition and i thought you
know what
we got to make kelly happy here she's
fading in the booth so let's read let's
read some of these off can i hit you
with one let's
i'd prefer you not hit hit me but yeah
you can
i don't think i could hurt you if i did
agree who's one speaker author or
thinker who's made a big impact on you
who man
one speaker
off top of my head um author
man there's some old authors that i love
like twain and those guys but um
recent terry reels is an important
author for me
um speaker i'll tell you what man
uh jade simmons this weekend or this
week and will gudera the restaurateur
and the
pianist man jade simmons and will gadara
were just lights out speakers and just
humans to be around um so yeah they're
very inspirational um good stuff i'll
give you the sunday school answer dave
ramsey oh my god
but for real though seth godin i love
his books brilliant thinker brilliant
author always an inspiring read uh
speaker absolutely dave for sure john
deloney second
second huh yep
that's fair i would have gone one two
punch have you ever walked out on a
movie or concert what was it oh this is
gonna be controversial okay i've walked
out of two concerts in my life just
because they were so bad oh
number one bob dylan
ouch i was it was that bad devastated at
how bad it was i just couldn't wrap my
head in his old age you just couldn't
swing it anymore yeah it was rough i
don't know if she's having a bad day it
was just rough
i didn't know what was happening and
we're off the air john just i know and
to all of you i know he's the greatest
of all time and parches in a pear tree
and he's a great songwriter and yadda
yadda my whole family was singing along
to some bob dylan today in the car so
it's not that it's a concert it's rough
and then maroon 5.
i couldn't hang man too many tats no not
the tats are fine it was like the skin
tight black tank top and like kind of
giving it to the mic stand a little bit
i was like dude i'm not for you i think
i'm good that's amazing what about you
uh so one comes to memory it's a sad
story my ex-girlfriend um
we went to see grizzly bear and
radiohead two of my favorite bands okay
we get stuck in traffic we miss grizzly
bear she's so upset that we leave early
when radiohead starts playing y'all
didn't stay we didn't stay she was so
upset i don't know i was i missed
arguably one of the greatest bands in
the history of music yep
because for a temper tantrum huh that
was the beginning of the end for me john
i can see how that worked that way i was
out what's a song that makes your ears
bleed
um there's a few anything by smashing
pumpkins the whole catalog wow uh hey
man you're an all-star get your game on
go play just when any time that i hear
the song i'm like ah i gotta go
um those are the two wow what about you
uh song that makes my ears bleed who let
the dogs out gives me hemorrhoids they
don't make my ears bleed as much as it
makes it fire out the back end
i'm trying to probably stuff that you
listen to would make my ears bleed i
could see that yeah i can see that i
don't know i can't think of any of the
top of my head social media is it good
for us or bad for us and why um i think
it's 95 percent not good
five percent good oh that's a good take
i was going to go 95 good
bad i know but you're wrong most of the
time i know it is a dark place but i i
do think it's an amazing technology that
allows us to do amazing things right we
just it's not social media's fault it's
our fault there you go it's what i'm
trying to say i think there was a time
when cocaine was used as it was it was
people understood there was a medicinal
benefit to it it was in coca-cola and
then well it was also used for nasal
surgeries and things we misused it and
then it got misused and now
they took it away from everybody last
one what's your favorite cheap meal that
you'll always love no matter how much
money you make oh dorito tacos no
question wow
that fast taco bell man they do things
right
john just because it's cheap i mean they
cost your health
you still love it it gives me my joy
temporarily and then it gives you gas it
incredible amounts but so good what
about you kelly regrets ever handing us
these cards what about you you know i'm
a chipotle fan
i cost 72 dollars for a burrito how's
that your cheap not the way i do it i'm
so busy i get four meals out of one bowl
you take your tesla over there and
why don't you bring the test lap just
going slumming with the chipotle listen
i try to i try to use chipotle it's an
anniversary meal in my house that's
unbelievable well fast food's tough for
me i mean chick-fil-a kids meal that's a
go-to for me that i get a lot of
judgment for you officially are on
friendship probation and you should stop
talking let's go to joseph in kalamazoo
hey joe what's up
hey guys i'm sorry you had to hear that
joseph i apologize yes
all good all good what's up brother
hey um so i am 22 years old and i have
20k in debt and i
am currently paying off three very
predatory payday loans that are eating
me alive inside i'm sick and tired of
being sick and tired awesome
so how can we help man
well
i guess first and foremost those three
payday loans have some of the most
egregious uh apr rates i've seen in my
entire life two of them have one of them
has 400 and the worst one out of the
three has 690 apr
40 payments
what is there a prepay penalty
there is no prepay penalty how much is
in all three of those bonds how much are
they no
in some the worst though in some it's
about 100 800
i'd say about 1100 in total all three
how much do you make
i make about 45 000 a year after taxes
what caused you to go to a payday lender
out of all people in the first place
um
i've been struggling living paycheck to
paycheck and and i had no emergency fund
and most of my bank account is either
negative or has barely a few ones in it
and so i've had to make some pretty hard
decisions uh poor decisions nonetheless
but uh
all right so here's what we're gonna do
uh i'm gonna turn over georgia for a
second but um
i want you to get a couple of bricks
once you go find them even if you have
to go to the grocery i mean to the
hardware store and pay pay 50 cents for
one okay get a couple of them
i want you to get some masking tape and
put it on there
or just get a magic marker and write on
there
stupid thing you did a dumb loan and a
dumb loan or i got desperate and i found
myself negative whatever
i want you to hold that sucker for a
minute until it's heavy
and then i want you to go to the nearest
lake or river and throw it in there
and be
done with this okay because here's what
i can hear your voice the shame of what
happened to you is
prohibiting you from launching into
outer space to get this stuff knocked
out
every step you take is you're carrying
the well yeah so stupid i can't believe
this and now this 600 percent interest
rate is a slap in your face every day
but you're feeling it as a stupid tax
right
yeah stop damn stop get done with it
joseph how much money do you have in the
bank right now
negative 445 dollars
so sorry what's your day job
i uh i'm an hvac uh heating and cooling
technician okay can you work extra hours
yes i can okay i'm going to be working
80 hours a week until this mess is
cleaned up and i'm definitely focusing
on these insane payday loans first and
you're going to be on a shoestring
budget eating rice and beans more than
ever before my favorite meal so that's
that's good news and what i'm going to
do is i'm going to hook you up with a
financial coaching session with one of
our trained financial coaches and gift
you one year of ramsay plus to dive into
the budget focus on that because that's
what you can control and every dollar is
going to have a name and we're not gonna
spend
any money on anything but this debt and
keeping the lights on
that's it are you in
i am in boom austin's gonna pick up
we're gonna make sure he gets you
connected to one of our financial
coaches and ramsey plus watch all the
financial peace videos i want you to get
so angry at this that you are standing
outside of the payday lender with a sign
that says avoid this scam and i want you
driving for uber or uber eats or
something by this weekend you got 48
hours to make that happen i want you
down at local coffee shop working from 4
00 a.m to 7 00 a.m to get another three
hours in go pick up a shift in the
evenings washing dishes
your life is over for the next 24 months
and then
everything
looks different how do payday lenders
sleep at night i have no idea a very
comfortable mattress is paid on the
desperation of hurting 190 interest
is there a bigger scam in america
[Music]
it's disgusting
sorry my brother hang on we'll be right
back
[Music]
so
[Music]
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window covering you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use promo code ramsey to get the
best deal rules and restrictions apply
today's question comes from brandon in
indiana
should i move out of my parents basement
or not i'm 21 and i earn 2800 a month
the apartment that i'm considering is
900 a month my parents think it's the
dumbest idea ever because i'm getting
married soon they believe i should wait
until i'm married and then buy a house
with my wife i would prefer to get my
own apartment which my fiance would move
into when we marry so we can save
together for a house
is it smarter to stay in my parents
basement and save money until i get
married or get my own place now and
finally be on my own i'm ready to grow
up and learn how to love life but i feel
like my parents are holding me back and
i have no one in my life to give me real
advice
that took a turn at the end there
very confusing oh man
on this show we often get a run of 21
year olds who are incredible and doing
great things and then occasionally we
get the email from a 20 21 year old and
we go there it is there it is
so um i want you to be grown up on your
own too and by the tone of this email
you're not there yet
uh i think everybody here is i don't i
don't have any problem whatsoever
with you living with your parents until
you get married you're a few months out
and i don't know what getting married
soon means to some people that's two
years into sometimes two months but
man if you're getting married in a few
months hang on
part of growing up is delaying
gratification doing the hard thing
because it's going to be better for you
in the long run man
there's got to be more here because just
living in your parents basement i don't
know if they're overbearing or they're
mean or they're abusive or who knows but
just based on this email dude stick it
out and then i wouldn't buy a house i'd
get an apartment right i mean yes i
wouldn't run by a house that i can't
afford to go rent somewhere for a year
once you're married stack up a whole
bunch of cash because by the looks of it
i doesn't sound like he's ready to even
buy a house on the financial side just
the
logistics of it so i would rent for a
year
once you're married
then save up a bunch of cash and then
buy a house at that point if you guys
feel like you're ready it's that simple
i think it's important to note
i'm ready to quote unquote grow up um
that that phrase gets people into
trouble sometimes they go out and buy
cars that they can't afford they buy
homes they can't afford they run off and
accelerate relationships into long-term
like binding long-term agreements like
marriage before they're ready and under
the guise of i just need to grow up it's
time whatever that means well he's
getting married at 21 which is fairly
young very very young yeah yeah very
young and so that's fine i'm gonna hate
on that but
man you get some wisdom in your life if
you cannot trust your parents for wisdom
you need to find a couple of men in your
community whether that's an old coach or
an old band instructor or a pastor in
your community that you trust somebody
to sit down and not just ask a bunch of
questions to but somebody say hey i'm
getting married in a few months
would you start having coffee with me
once a week just so i can
i i need some wisdom and i'm not getting
it from home so i'm gonna go find it
somewhere and pre-marital counseling
would be great if you haven't done that
really important great place to get
advice yeah because the other person
you're leaving out of this equation is
your wife uh does she want to have an
apartment which i mean
where do you want to live where are you
going to work we just there's a lot of
pieces of the equation here we got to
figure out yeah but i'll tell you
brother brandon slow down slow down make
a game plan the game plan is not i'm
ready to grow up the game plan is how
much money do i need to get into an
apartment when i get married how long am
i going to be here what's the agreement
with my parents and so on and so forth
so get a plan man and just reverse
engineer it and work the plan let's go
to evelyn in dayton ohio what's up
evelyn is it elvin alvin sorry
alvin dude i blew that
i'm sorry elvin
you're good
how's it going i'm if i could read it'd
be going better but i'm doing good man
how about you
doing great hey a little background here
i am going to be quitting my job here in
about a week why are you quitting going
to something new why are you quitting um
just uh time to move on i should say
long story but yeah okay usually that
means there's a big long story but go
for it
so i'm in the residential construction
business
i'm currently a project manager cabinet
designer
21 years old been married for about nine
months
and have about
eighty thousand dollars in cash debt
free okay nice
so i am
looking to either go to another
contractor uh doing project managing as
well
for relatively the same pay
or go out on my own as a carpenter
okay what would be your recommendation
just
i was just thinking you know where the
economy is
didn't want to go in head over heels
thinking i can make it and then are you
going to have a gap in income if you're
quitting in a week and the other one's
not lined up do you have this other job
it would be
right into the next job okay so i would
do both if i were you that's my take
john may disagree but i would take this
other job and start to build your
carpentry business on the side and see
if you like it and see if you can get
clients and ongoing clients and create
enough income that you can slowly take a
step from the dock onto the boat
if that's what you want well i i have
done that in the past so i've been doing
side jobs for
i don't know probably
two years
um have you made enough money that you
think you could
make this your full-time gig
uh i believe so i mean i got basically
five jobs waiting on me right now if i
were to take them what's driving you
towards doing your own thing versus
working for someone
uh just being able to
um
you know set my own schedule
and
um
you know hopefully make some more money
i've talked to several
individuals that do finish carpentry in
the area and they have all told me to go
on your end there's plenty of work out
there it's not like
you're not going to find work
um
the one thing that's given me pause
alvin is
response to george's question do you
make enough money and you said i think
so
and so
for whatever reason i would say for that
i would say yes okay yes i do well you
do for for four jobs right and as a uh
what you have to ask yourself is
how many of the jobs am i getting are
offshoots of the
project management job i'm doing
do i have money for marketing or do i
have some sort of way to go get a new
book of business to build something
while i'm doing the job and also
marketing and also taking the calls and
making sure i'm hitting all of my so
you have to have a fully realized
business plan before you decide to take
this brand new wife of yours on a ride
right you've got four jobs so
i want to hear your answer to do you
have money lined up yes i've got four
jobs in the hopper i've already done x
and done y and i've joined this trade
association and i'm doing this and then
you're going to be all ready
how much do you make at your project
management job
um
gross about
61.50
okay
um just off what i've just recently paid
a carpenter you should be able to make
that in a year do you feel confident
about that
yes i do okay
so i want you to be very specific and if
this is something that's outside your
wheelhouse which it would be for most
people
sit down with somebody who can help you
do the math on that and say here's how
much insurance is going to cost both
insurance for my jobs that i'm going to
have to have because you're going to be
bonded and insured
and your your insurance is going to go
like get down and map all that out
do i have the truck do i have the nails
do i've got the equipment am i going to
have to go put 30 000 of new saws and
screwdrivers on
on credit card or do i actually have i
want you to do all of that math
and then say now i'm ready to start a
business i got four jobs lined up i can
make five calls i want you to have ten
jobs in the hopper i want five i got
five more down downstream you see what
i'm doing there i'm being really certain
as george said the boat i'm about to
jump into
is solid it doesn't sound like it's
there yet it sounds like it's close but
it doesn't sound like it's there yet
okay
yep
yeah that's the confidence i needed john
right there tell me i'm wrong i want you
to go no bullcrap dude i've got it i'm
ready i want to hear some fight in your
voice alvin i want to hear that you want
to be a small business owner and this is
what you were born to do but right now
it sounds like you're kind of like yeah
i don't know here's the deal hang on the
line probably because i'm a little bit
intimidated so oh don't be intimidated
by me dude i'm not very tough at all but
listen hang on the line here and i'm
going to send you a copy of dave
ramsey's small business playbook the
entree leadership
and it will walk you through step by
step and before you quit all things
i want you to walk through this book and
say okay i am officially ready to do
this and man we need more good
carpenters out there who are ethical and
show up on time and tell the truth go
get them
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture of today of the day
comes from psalm 143 10.
teach me to do your will for you or my
god
may your good spirit lead me on level
ground
ralph waldo emerson says self-trust
is the first secret of success
imagine the energy of a jam-packed arena
with people ready to experience what it
means to live life to the fullest
picture all your favorite speakers
together on one stage empowering you
with tools and principles that will
create unstoppable momentum in your life
that is smart conference
smart conference is back and it's been
three years and we are so pumped to get
this event back on the road we're going
to be in dallas texas on saturday
october 22nd
this is not
just a rally pep rally
like woo shaking pom-poms this is
thousands of people just like you coming
together under one roof to help you
create unstoppable momentum in your life
you'll learn how to build wealth achieve
your goals strengthen your relationships
and so much more but you won't just
learn you'll also have a great time
trust me we know how to party and have a
good time all of us here at ramsey will
be there and our special guest
craig and amy groschel from life church
are coming too tickets start at 39 bucks
that's a great price for an all-day
event like this you won't find a price
like that anywhere get your tickets now
before they sell out there they've sold
thousands and thousands already visit
ramseysolutions.com
events to learn
more let's go to tara in corpus christi
what's up tara
hi chair hi this is tara how are you
this is john good to talk to you tara
how's it going
good good what's up i have a question um
that i need help with a little bit of
guidance with them my husband and i have
recently
come into some money from a sale of uh
his business and uh he is in a
non-compete for a year and a half for
what he did
at the previous job and i
am working
part-time so a little bit of income
coming in but
our
our basically our net worth right now is
approximately four million we've got um
a condo that's worth a million dollars
that we're going to be renting out in
another month
that um potentially would make about
about a couple of thousand a month
and we have a home that's paid off
that's worth um 1 million
and we have
about
2 million
1.5 cash and the rest is like a mutual
fund
1.5 million in cash is this from the
sale of the business we have
correct we haven't invested that part
yet okay wow way to go
thank you
so
51. wow
awesome okay 51.
yes and we are um
i guess toying with the idea of taking
uh but him he has to take a year and a
half off from his work because of my
compete
and
we are thinking about possibly just not
working both of us not working for a
year and a half traveling a little bit
possibly investing in another home in
colorado
to
fix up and sell or maybe to even put in
a rental market um
and we just don't know if i should stop
working i have a potential to make about
a hundred thousand dollars a year if i
went back full time
um
and
or any time really i mean i can go back
in a year and a half as well and make
the same amount but
is it a wise decision or is it a risky
too risky of a decision to take that
year and a half off to go enjoy
ourselves and do something we want to do
and then get back into the workforce in
about a year and a half so all that i'll
let george answer the math part of this
um here's a couple of big red flags i've
got
number one you've backed yourself into a
corner of either working
or enjoying ourselves and i do not think
those things are mutually exclusive
especially at the level you two are
operating
the second thing is
is i would want to be really intentional
about what you think you're going to get
out of a year and a half of not working
here's why
most people have fallen under the
illusion that the goal of life is to get
to a place where i can do nothing
and that's a dangerous dangerous place
to be i spent some time with jay leno
this week he's 72 i think does 200 dates
a year that's a lot of flying around the
country but when i asked him he's like
why would i
i love this
and so the idea of not doing this sounds
more punitive than actually like i made
it i don't have enough mud right same
with dave dave has no reason to be in
work financially but he it it brings him
joy and it's what uh helping and serving
and loving people is what what fills his
his cup so
what i would challenge you on is what do
you think you and your husband are going
to gain by just pausing life for a year
the third thing is is absolutely i would
not
buy a house
14 hours from your home
to renovate and then rent out being a
long distance landlord is a disaster
it's tough
and if you buy a nice house you fix it
up and you end up with a management
company that's going to be for you are
your margin of return is going to be
much lower i'd much rather see you get
some houses there in corpus and fix
those up or buy beach house or whatever
you want to do with your money
but it sounds like
you all just want something different
and you've got money now is that fair
yes it is okay i that's a whole
different conversation
because that's two people that say hey
we've worked this hard like like we've
worked like maniacs and we're 50 we're
about halfway home on this whole
adventure
what do we want to do and that's a
totally different conversation then well
let's try this let's just take your off
let's do that you see what i'm saying
mm-hmm because you're going to wake up
in a year and here's going to be the
best part of it you had a year off it's
going to be cool the worst part of it is
that you're going to go with you
and this person who wants a different
life who wants to feel different become
different wants to have a different
different level of intimacy and their
marriage wants fill in the blank wants
to live in a different part of the
country that person's still going to be
there you're just going to be a year
older you're going to be a year's worth
of not working
with less money right and then you're
going to have made some some decisions
i'm going to buy this house i'm going to
do this that's going to feel like i'm
doing a thing you're not doing a thing
right what's it going to cost to travel
for a year and a half and do what you
guys want to do
a lot
like give me a hundred thousand
okay
well
okay well our expenses where our son is
still in college so we're still cash
flowing that so that's about 4 000 a
month
and in addition to that it would be
maybe
another i would i would say would be
at a minimum of 5 000 a month so it
looks like over 10 000
for expenses every month at least okay
so yes what's your husband what was his
what was give me a i know you can't be
specific what give me a general
what did he do
health care sales okay so is he going to
continue being a salesman once he
once is not competes over
um he's he's thinking about doing
something a little bit different but in
health care yeah do you want to continue
to live the life of a salesman's wife
no
that's what i thought you all need to
have that conversation
so the truth is financially on paper
yeah you can do this it's not going to
break the bank you can still retire with
dignity but to john's point i would ask
myself what am i going to get out of
this why am i doing this what kind of
life do we want long term so we don't
come back from this trip and go what now
we feel empty again
so you still have a lot of life ahead of
you the life of a salesman
can be
well it wasn't he was not in sales he um
the product that he developed they sold
okay okay
no
so this
if we had 20 or 30 more minutes this
feels like a relationship conversation
that
okay you have not sat down and said
here's what i i've got i've got 50 years
left the math works in my favor
and
here's what i have pictured of that
looking like and it's not this
can you go travel for a month and then
come back and go all right how do we
feel
yeah we thought about that as well
because i do have a job potentially
lined up and i could start in another
month or so so that would be i like this
compromise
and this could be a great opportunity
for your husband to retool and get some
education and some new skills that he's
going to need to learn in the next
chapter of his life but all of this
starts with you guys going to breakfast
together and spending half a day
doing a postmortem here's the first 50
years we've been married for this long
here's where we are
what do we want the next half this thing
to look like and you are gonna have to
be honest here about your needs moving
forward hey thanks to kelly and will and
aj and zach and the gang back there in
the booth george great show awesome
times thank you john america thank you
so much for hanging out with us be kind
to one another
get outside
and go play we'll see you soon on the
ramsay show
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you